[Música]
eu nunca tinha pensado antes o quanto é
necessário a gente parar para falar
sobre a qualidade de convivência que nós
temos
a convivência que nós temos com a gente
mesmo e à convivência que a gente tem
com os outros
faz sentido pra vocês que nós não
estamos em guerra mas não estamos
confortáveis com que a gente está
vivendo a antes de chegar aqui até vocês
eu conversei com muitas pessoas e que me
falaram do desconforto tanto da
experiência que ela tem com elas mesmas
em termos de convivência com aquelas
coisas fim
não tenho tempo pra mim
o dia parece que precisa de mais horas
para conseguir dar atenção pra mim mesma
o telefone e me chama o tempo todo eu
fico dedicado ao telefone esperando que
chega uma mensagem que eu vou mandar uma
mensagem e aí quando eu vejo já acabou o
tempo não tenho tempo pra mim alguém se
identifica com isso também houve muitas
pessoas falando da convivência com o
outro e aí eu fui buscar um pouco nas
minhas experiências de trabalho e houve
muita liderança dizendo que o que eles
enfrentam hoje nas empresas na no poder
público nas escolas nas universidades
não é necessariamente a dificuldade com
o trabalho que é desenvolvido ali mas a
dificuldade na convivência alguém se
identifica com isso a
eu posso dizer da minha experiência é
disso que se trata com termos aqui um
pouco da nossa experiência a minha
experiência de convivência comigo eu tô
num momento fui muito confortável de de
buscar o meu melhor e aí é uma prática
do todo dia eu como é que eu posso estar
melhor como é que eu posso ser uma
pessoa melhor estava melhor e também
fazer com que as pessoas que estejam
comigo sintam-se melhor mas eu tive uma
experiência de convivência familiar e
comunitária que eu preciso contar a
vocês pra vocês entenderem porque o meu
trabalho diz de convivência e porque
isso pra mim é tão forte
eu cresci num ambiente muito acolhedor e
de muita solidariedade
eu convivi com homens e mulheres de raça
diferente de cultura diferente de
religiosidade diferente mas que para um
pra conversar ea conversa era sobre as
questões que tínhamos ali para resolver
e pensar estratégias de como é que a
gente faz isso como é que a gente
resolve essas questões que são comuns
então eles tinham um objetivo comum que
era muito claro esse objetivo era
transformar a melhor a qualidade de vida
e de convívio daquela comunidade
não era só estrutura mas ela também como
a gente poderia ficar melhor a lei é e
era muito vivo muito vivo
o sentido de vizinhança de amizade de
solidariedade de refil proximidade é
tudo aquilo que é que propicia uma maior
vinculação e conexão uns com os outros
nós nos conhecemos e éramos
ah eu conhecia todas aquelas pessoas
elas me conheciam eu me sentia parte e
naquele contexto eu era alguém acham
isso importante que nós seres humanos
estejamos em ambientes onde você sabe
qual é o seu papel e que você tem
importância lê e que naquele coletivo
você é tá seguro que ali têm confiança
então é deste lugar que eu estou falando
dessa experiência e eu intuitivamente
fui levando essa experiência para a vida
o meu trabalho para outros espaços que
não era a minha comunidade mas que
passou a ser né
depois disso virou uma metodologia isso
virou uma metodologia eu tenho
trabalhado na universidade nas escolas
nas empresas né favorecendo criando
ambientes de convivência fazendo com que
as pessoas possam se sentir melhor umas
com as outras
daí colaborarem e fazer todas aquelas
coisas que quando você se sente bem você
é capaz de fazer
acompanhando tudo bem aí e convivência
eu gosto de pensar na questão da
convivência como experiência que
conectam dentro e fora de dentro e fora
as experiências
as experiências boas collection e as
experiências ruins elas diz connection
eu gostaria de dizer que eu tive como
mentor como mestre como uma pessoa que
me inspirou na vida
a figura do meu pai meu pai era um líder
comunitário
dona de um carisma impressionante e dona
de uma vontade inquebrantável e ele
era sempre uma coisa de fazer junto uma
coisa de estar junto com os outros é
conquistando coisas né e o isso que com
ele eu aprendi profundamente o que é
fazer política o que é fazer parte de
uma rede social
estar com os outros e descobrir
objetivos comuns e mais do que tudo
sustentar valores nem meu pai dizia
sempre assim
filhão seja honesta e quando ele dizia
'honestidade estava dizendo seja começa
com você mesma janela com os outros se
você puder ser honesta não é
as portas sempre estarão abertas para
você e eu acho que ele tinha razão
já a minha mãe ensinou muito sobre amor
conciliação e diálogo
a minha mãe até hoje a mãe tem 92 anos é
aquela matriarca que ouvir a todos na
família e ela consegue ouvir por um
ângulo foi o outro não tem preocupação
de julgar
tenho a preocupação de compreender iii
novamente fazer ali uma situação boa de
corrigir é a minha intenção aqui hoje é
levantar algumas questões e apresentar
algumas idéias de como a gente pode
fazer melhor por nós mesmos e pelos
outros
em termos de convivência quantos de
vocês gostariam de melhorar a qualidade
de convivência que tem consigo mesmo e
com os outros
quantos uau então estamos na mesma
página estamos falando das mesmas coisas
e isso não importa em que lugar
exatamente estejamos falando se é
campinas são paulo peru bolivia é
estamos neste momento da história
precisando conectar com a gente mesmo e
melhorar a qualidade de conexão que a
gente tem com os outros e para isso
trouxe
as inspirações duas inspirações e não
por coincidência da áfrica e é
importante dizer que nós brasileiros
temos tanto que a informação sobre a
áfrica chega muito pouco da áfrica pra
gente e quando chega coisas da áfrica
nem sempre são coisas com as quais a
gente se identifique
eu gostaria de usar desapropriar mas
essas duas inspirações
eu acredito que são verdadeiros
presentes não só para o brasil mas para
o mundo
a primeira inspiração eu quero falar de
adin contra alguém sabe que adquira a
dica é são é uma escrita bic fotográfica
o símbolo está associado à preservação e
à transmissão de valores
estamos falando de convivência e eu
trago para vocês né preservar valores e
transmitir valores e se a dica que se
estão vendo na tela é o adquira mais
conhecido é o sam cofa e esse e muitos
outros a dicas
esses símbolos que levam consigo valores
ele é muito utilizado na parte oeste da
áfrica
too gana costa do marfim é fofa de todos
é o símbolo da sabedoria e se passa o
que olha para trás é o pássaro que quer
nos lembrar que nós devemos aprender com
o passado pra agir transformar um
presente e avançar para o futuro é esse
pássaro e quando a gente olha para os
han copa e sabe qual é o valor
isso nos lembra não nos deixa esquecer
de qual é o valor que você
sustentar porque é disso que se trata
qual é o valor de convivência que cada
um de vocês quer sustentar
pra que a gente tenha recuperada a
qualidade de convívio com a gente mesmo
e com os outros qual é uma pergunta na
eco bag de vocês todos vocês receberam
de presente fiz questão de trazer isso
pra vocês para que conheçam
mas tá mais do que conhecer inspire a
conhecer o odin cá né e levar consigo
esses valores da da convivência é uma
outra inspiração que eu trago aqui pra
vocês é o bumbum
é possível que você já tenha ouvido
falar sobre esse conceito
alguns de vocês né o google tem uma
palavra conceito que quer dizer só quem
só por aquilo que todos somos olha isso
sou quem sou por aquilo que todos somos
quando eu ouvi esse conceito pela
primeira vez eu pensei muito em
solidariedade pensei muito e união
pensei é e amor fraterno né
revisitando esse conceito hoje eu
entendo que o a ubuntu que nós hoje já
conhecemos aqui no brasil
ele vem para nos ensinar a quem não
conhece essa história a quem não conhece
essa história é ser uma história é um
episódio real que aconteceu na áfrica de
um visitante é propõe por um grupo de
crianças de uma determinada aldeia que
elas façam uma corrida uma competição e
quem ganhasse aquela corrida daquela
competição ganhariam uma festa de doces
e guloseimas criança doce problemas é e
aí aconteceu uma coisa surpreendente
quando esse visitante deu o comando para
que as crianças conhecem elas sem se
olharem sem dizer uma única palavra ela
fizeram as mãos e correram todas juntas
todas juntas e óbvio que a gente vai
entendendo que tem um motivo
uma motivação para que as pessoas corram
juntas e que tem valores que sustentam e
se correr juntos e aí eu quero fazer um
convite a vocês porque eu acho que o
mundo está querendo nos avisar que a
gente pode um boom tar nós brasileiros
podemos perguntar e aí eu pediria a
vocês que olhem pra pessoa que tiver do
seu lado de preferência aquela que você
ainda nem viu hoje que a desconhecidos
eu olhe pra ela e sustente o olhar
quero que vocês apenas olhem que
sustentem olhar muito bem é isso mesmo
ea gente pode fazer esse silêncio porque
só olhar e porque eu peço a vocês que
sustentem olhar porque começa a olhar a
nossa convivência como começa no olhar e
no olhar empático no olhar apreciativo
que eu posso fazer pra outra pessoa que
está do meu lado que eu ainda não
conheço mas que se eu der um passo na
direção dela eu posso reconhecer coisas
que eu já conheço em mim e aí eu vou
dificultar pra vocês eu vou pedir a
vocês que têm as suas mostra quem
estiver do lado até com quem vocês não
conhecem a vamos dificultar isso e com
esse com esse esforço que vocês estão
fazendo eu queria que vocês só ouvissem
a pergunta que eu vou fazer a vocês e
não precisam responder mas pensem nisso
levem isso junto com vocês é pelo que
nós cada um de nós
está disposto a dar as mãos e correr
juntos pelo que se nós não estamos
felizes com a nossa convivência o ubuntu
pede a são aquelas crianças quando dão
as mãos e correm aqui é uma ação uma
afirmação de que nós podemos fazer
alguma coisa por nós mesmos pela
comunidade onde a gente vive pelas
grandes causas que que nos sensibiliza
convivência é estar em relação com os
outros não significa ocupar o mesmo
espaço físico das nossas casas da nossa
sala de aula do nosso escritório quer
onde a gente esteja vocês estão aqui
agora como também da convivência de
vocês estão devendo um dia inteiro de
ted juntos como tá fim da convivência eu
posso sair do meu quadrado eu posso
abrir me pra outra convivência que não
seja aquela que já já conheço já domino
né
eu queria deixar isso pra vocês de de
todo o coração dizendo que a gente pode
romper as barreiras do preconceito de
raça de gênero e de classe de
escolaridade todos eles para que a gente
possa estar uma relação eu tô na relação
humana que é o legítimo outro humano
porque a relação eu isso aquela relação
que eu conheci fico o outro não nos
ajude se empobrece
nós não precisamos de muita coisa
nós só precisamos gols dos outros
obrigado